[Música]
a un perro no le interesa las cosas
materiales sus bienes sus autos tu
dinero a un solo perro solo le interesa
un lugar dentro de tu corazón
los perros no maltratan el planeta no
deforestar no contaminan los ríos no
tienen una posición religiosa ni
política del menos racista
no tiene estudios y tiene una urgencia
de amar los humanos no nos damos cuenta
de esto tan fácil el amor tiene cuatro
letras tiene cuatro patas nariz no
diferencia el logro de la lata
solo basta ver la mirada de un perro
para ver el don del perdón por todo esto
jamás entenderé la pretensión del ser
humano crece mejor que el perro cuando
el hombre deberá volver a nacer de nuevo
para tener las virtudes de un animal o
de un perro gracias
buenas tardes ya saben quién soy yo para
mí es no es algo común como los otros
expositores que están acostumbrados
están en escenarios en viajes en todo
esto yo me dedico solamente a ayudar a
los animales de la calle por la
reproducción quiero saber si alguna vez
alguno de ustedes les han preguntado
si son felices amigos amantes novias
padres lo que ustedes quieran
bueno esa pregunta yo me había hecho y
ahí comenzó la transformación de mi vida
después de viajes después de trabajar en
corporaciones tan grandes en el mundo
tener a mi cargo cinco países para
trabajar y vivir en el avión durante 78
años vivir en hoteles de lujo al mostrar
en restaurantes de lujo cambio a la
caliente
de la noche a la mañana conocí a la
chocó un perro que está en san miguel
que lo han visto en las notas
internacionales
me lamió las manos y le compré comida
ahí comenzó toda mi historia y decidí
quedarme y dejar todo atrás
los perros vienen a producirse igual que
todos los animales en la tierra no
vienen a formar familias como lo hacemos
los humanos no necesitamos amigos
enemigos profesores nada de esto
necesitamos solamente el ver cómo
funciona la vida un animal vienen a
reproducirse cada uno de ellos en el
caso de los perros tenemos dos veces al
año se lo puede ser cuatro ocho o diez
crías en cada camada los perros tienen
dos camadas al año los gatos tienen 46 y
solamente multipliquen cuántos perros
puede reproducir una hembra en bolivia
tenemos casi 2 millones de perros en las
calles de bolivia en diferentes ciudades
de los cuales para mí ha sido
algo que tenía que cambiar y había
decidido tener una fundación hace más de
15 años para seguir los pasos de mis
abuelos pero el estar contacto con un
animal te enseña mucho más que tal vez
cuando estás cambiando y no sabes si
quieres irte o quedarte
si quieres o no quieres ir de la noche a
la mañana decidí mandar al [ __ ] todo
ganar muy bien viajes todo lo que
ustedes quieran no porque me sobre la
plata no porque crea que voy a tener
todo pero era un ideal y una meta como
un sueño de vida
en todos los barrios y ustedes siempre
van a ver a los perritos en las calles
que van pidiendo y van comiendo yo por
eso alimento a más de entre 2000 y 3000
derivando la comida muchas personas a
voluntarios que también están acá
hay casi un millón de perros en las
calles de bolivia de los cuales el 39
son hembras abandonadas y sí por lo
menos abandonar abandonaríamos
esterilizadas no tendríamos la
reproducción que vivía tenemos
lo que en el cálculo de esa cifra y
ustedes se van a dar cuenta cuántos
nacen cada día entre mayo junio y julio
de este año en la pasan ha sido más de
440 crías dónde van a ir si no tenemos
ya espacios en refugios sin albergues
las alcaldías no toman interés el
gobierno tome interés tal vez porque no
votan los perros posiblemente ahora que
estamos en elecciones pero estamos los
animalistas que somos un canal
no trata de pelear ni salir con nada
pero trato de seguir más
para poder sacar este problema mi sueño
y mi meta es regalar un monto muy alto
en estabilización es casi 2 millones de
perros me haré cargo de todos este
problema exigiendo al gobierno una ley
de prohibición de animales en bolivia 5
años si no no voy a gastar ni mi tiempo
ni mi plata igual que muchos animalistas
que existen en bolivia
el motivar a la adopción es sumamente
urgente porque estamos siendo cómplices
de comprar algo que nosotros nos sobra
son 500 personas en bolivia las que
viven de todos estos animales y no nos
damos cuenta que estamos dejando hablar
oportunidad a uno más es como que tienes
10 autos y quieres comprar uno más para
qué quieres uno más en mi caso yo dejado
yo no utilizo reloj no compro ropa hace
más de cuatro años gracias a dios he
tenido un ropero por las marcas en las
que he trabajado muy grande y hasta el
día de hoy me sirve hoy en día las
marcas se me mandan regalos las camisas
con las caras de mis perros van hechas
por diseñadores
no se olviden esto si quieren ayudar a
su país y a su ciudad adopte no entren a
hacer parte del juego de por tener un
perro de marca
es un mini yo tengo yo antes andaba en
autos de marca regalados también por mis
abuelos y ahora haré un minibús me han
debido haber muchas veces reconociendo
37 kilómetros diarios la ciudad
recogiendo comida y recogiendo los
tachos dando croquetas dar los
desperdicios de muchos restaurantes
lo único que les puedo enseñar es que
todos tenemos metas en la vida
no solamente como la anterior expositora
fíjense en la plata fíjense en lo que
ustedes quieren dejar de precedente que
la gente se acuerde de algo que ustedes
han hecho no sea uno más del montón que
porque todos quieren algo si gana eso
tengo tal vez la suerte y la capacidad
de tener mucha actitud y mucha
perseverancia cuatro años y medio que
hago esto paso navidades en las calles
paso año nuevos en las calles mi familia
prácticamente me quería de ser edad pero
he seguido fuera esto era esto era un
sueño de vida no gano plata de ninguna
institución ni de la de al día ni del
gobierno ni tampoco quiero un cargo para
seguir adelante para mí es más motivar
enseñar quieren ayudar hay niños hay
gente con cáncer hay gente con sida
ancianos
que pueden ayudar todos los días yo lo
hago de 10 a 11 horas diarias desde hace
4 años y medio y no lo digo yo soy un
capo lo puedo hacer podemos hacerlo de
acuerdo a nuestras necesidades pueden
hacer una vez a la semana una vez al mes
una vez al año lo que ustedes quieren
donan
todo sirve yo he aprendido que a mí me
sirve a mí me regalan plata en la calle
yo estoy andando y me regalan 10 pesos
20 pesos al principio claro me chocaba
porque decía como que estoy como mendigo
pero no es eso es la actitud de la gente
que quiere dar ayudarte
la historia más grande que puedo
enseñarles y mostrarles es que uno de
mis perritos peleaba con un mendigo en
la iglesia de san miguel hace tres años
por los huesos que yo dejaba sea un
humano peleaba por basura
me quedé en grado
y mi de arriba y le decía qué quieres
que aprenda qué lección tengo que no
debía dejar los medios
desde ese día hay bastantes
pordioseros que ayudó de alimento compró
en los puestos sándwiches giros lo que
ustedes quieran porque también tienen
hambre son humanos si se dan cuenta o
sea como pueden ver a un humano pelearse
con un animal por sobras
desgraciadamente eso es lo que tenemos
que vivir
para mí es un honor estar acá con todos
ustedes transmitirles lo que pueden
aprender y hacer que sus vidas no se
pongan
en su círculo vean más allá para poder
ayudar a la causa que ustedes quieran me
encantaría poder ayudar a niños también
ancianos también pero los perros se
reproducen diariamente el perro es un
animal nosotros somos humanos no nos
podemos poner a la misma entonces qué
hago ayudar primero motivar a enseñar en
los cuatro pilares dar comida la
educación en los talleres en los
colegios en las universidades en las
empresas
he conseguido más de diez empresas de
las más grandes de bolivia para que
interactúe conmigo transportando
animales bancos que tenemos bancos pet
friendly que ni siquiera en eeuu existen
y compañías de seguro y gris y es me voy
tocando puertas y se van abriendo el
tercer paso es esterilizar y el cuarto
es tener el santuario el santuario es
sinónimo de asilo para humanos donde me
llevo a los más viejitos y a los más
enfermos y el mismo lugar me sirve para
esterilizar dios mediante espero que
contando de este día en cinco años
cumplí mi sueño que no existan animales
de las calles de mi país
gracias